herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live es
geht um corona es geht um unsere kinder
und jugendlichen vor knapp vor etwas
über einer stunde gab es die eilmeldung
die gesundheitsminister haben
beschlossen mehr ins angebote für
minderjährige ab 12 jahren
was ist der hintergrund die ferien gehen
hier und da zu ende
immer mehr eltern kommen mit ihren
kindern aus dem urlaub zurück und im
gepäck jede menge fragen wie geht es
denn weiter wie soll der schulstart
aussehen schule und das neue schuljahr
unter corona bedingungen die
gesundheitsminister von bund und länder
haben nun die 12 bis 17 jährigen in den
fokus heute genommen und wollen das
impfen für diese altersgruppe für die
zwölf- bis 17-jährigen tuschen und das
obwohl die ständige impfkommission bei
ihrer position bleibt nicht generell das
impfen für 12 bis 17 jähriger zu
empfehlen
das hat es noch nicht gegeben dass sich
die politik über die ständige
impfkommission hinweggesetzt hat wir
wollen darüber reden mit ihnen
diskutieren ihre fragen beantworten zu
gast haben wir im studio professor fred
zepp ehemaliger direktor des zentrums
für kinder und jugendmedizin an der uni
mainz und vor allem mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission schön dass sie
gekommen sind
guten abend verfüge und zugeschaltet ist
uns aus köln professor lauterbach der
spd-gesundheitsexperte vielen dank dass
sie auch zeit haben und mitdiskutieren
zunächst aber wollen wir uns anschauen
was haben die gesundheitsminister heute
genau beschlossen der beschluss der
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
sieht vor allen zwölf bis 17 jährigen
bis ende des monats ein impfangebot zu
machen
die impfungen in dieser altersgruppe
sollen in dem zuge auf die impfzentren
ausgeweitet werden
die möglichkeit die dosen in arztpraxen
zu erhalten bleibt weiterhin bestehen
zudem soll die spritze für jugendliche
auch bei betriebsärzten machbar sein zb
beim arbeitgeber der eltern
die länder streben außerdem impf
angebote für junge erwachsene an
universitäten berufsschulen und schulen
an
laut beschluss soll das maßgeblich zu
einem sicheren start in den lehr und
lern betrieb nach den sommerferien
beitragen
erst mal die frage an sie was sagen sie
zu der entscheidung der politik den 12
bis 17 jährigen allen jetzt ein impf
angebot zu machen das ganze zu
verstärken das ganze zu pushen ist das
nicht eine gute sache ich sag mal so die
politik kann natürlich eine solche
entscheidung treffen
der impfstoff ist ja zugelassen ab dem
alter von zwölf jahren und man muss sich
nur darüber klar sein eine zulassung ist
keine impfempfehlung sondern bei der
zulassung prüft eine behörde ob sondern
das was der hersteller des impfstoffes
vorträgt ob das durch die studie
bestätigt worden ist und dann lässt er
in diesen rahmenbedingungen den
impfstoff zu und eine impfempfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission etwas völlig
anderes wir bewegen uns innerhalb der
zulassung
es gibt ja auch eine influenza
zugelassenen impfstoff ohne dass wir den
empfehlen und prüfen ob es sinnvoll ist
in für eine bestimmte altersgruppe dann
eine impfung umzusetzen und das bedeutet
aber auch abzuwägen was verhindert was
können wir erreichen mit der impfung in
dieser altersgruppe und welche risiken
gehen wir an und das ist natur gewesen
so dass wir wenn wir jetzt impfstoffe
beraten über die wir gerade mal ein paar
monate erfahrungshorizont haben das ist
pandemie das was völlig anderes als was
wir üblicherweise in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten getan haben dann ist das
wissen begrenzt deshalb sind die
zulassung auch zeitlich befristet es
sind bedingte zulassung und deshalb ist
die ezb auch gezwungen nachzujustieren
beispiel ist sie hat den impfstoff
zugelassen dann kann die ersten
meldungen über heißt muskeln
entzündungen und dann hat die immer die
hätte jetzt die zulassung zurücknehmen
können das ist aber ein relativ
einschneidender schritt und was hat die
immer gemacht sie macht den warnhinweis
rhein steht drin
unter punkt 4 steht drin also man muss
es wissen dass das auftreten kann etwa 1
oder 20.000 impfungen und damit muss man
sich auseinandersetzen und in diesem
datenlage bewegen wir uns auf das heißt
die stiko ist ja eine institution die
impfungen unterstützt aber auch prüfen
muss ob eine impfung in einer gegebenen
situation in einem land in diesem und in
den usa ganz andere situationen dann
auch zuverlässig sicher ist und das ist
ein prozess der kontinuierlich abläuft
die stiko trifft sich
mehr als einmal pro woche virtuell im
internet in zusammenschaltung und sag
mal bewertet die aktuelle datenlage und
da ist es so dass wir bisher gesagt
haben wir haben keine schweren verläufe
in deutschland wir haben aber schon
dreistellige zahlen von yucca titel bei
jungen erwachsenen gesehen das sind
müssen sie wieder und
herzmuskelentzündungen die quasi in das
phänomen darstellen sind ja keine beran
entzündungen die wir im prinzip auch
schon bei menschen unter 30 beobachtet
haben werden noch größere zahlen den usa
und niemand von uns weiß ob aus dieser
blockade sind 20 jahre
herzrhythmusstörungen entsteht weil wir
einfach den beobachtungs horizont nicht
haben und aus diesem grund sind wir
zurückhaltend aber trotzdem
wir beobachten dass weiter und es ist
nicht so dass die stiko sich gegen die
impfung ausspricht sondern sie sagt nur
im augenblick können wir nicht
garantieren nicht wirklich das was ein
echter benefit ist das mag aber sich
auch noch mal ändern zum beispiel wenn
wir jetzt die krankheitssituation bei
einer möglichen vierten welle beobachten
müssen
da könnte das ja neu beurteilt werden
also never ever sind wir fest gefahren
sondern wir versuchen bloss für die
menschen unserer verantwortung gerecht
zu werden möglichst zuverlässig ihnen
ein sicheres konzept an die hand zu
geben
jetzt habe ich mal auf was sie gerade
gesagt haben sie die stiko sagt eben die
kogit 19 verläufe sind bei jüngeren ja
nicht so schwer und das ist so diese
risiko nutzen abwägung herr lauterbach
sie sagen zu der entscheidung der
politik heute das ist richtig das haben
sie in den vergangenen tagen schon
gesagt sie unterstützen den beschluss
aber warum denn die verläufe sind ja
jetzt nicht so schwer bei den jüngeren
also spricht den 12 bis 17 jährigen
unterstützen was er gesagt hat die stiko
ist eine unfassbar wertvolle einrichtung
der wir viel verdanken auch für die
vielen vielen jahren und macht eine
tolle arbeit und ich möchte ausdrücklich
darauf hinweisen dass ich es falsch wenn
da noch einer einrichtung wie die stiko
politisch druck ausgeübt wird somit auch
so die entscheidung der also stiko
empfehlung nicht auszusprechen die euch
aufgegangen märz gesprochen
es ist ich finde die entscheidung nicht
richtig aber auf der anderen seite ist
es eine entscheidung
die also durch ein gremium getroffen
wird welches qualitativ sehr hochwertig
besetzte von profis die das über viele
jahre ohne interessenskonflikte machen
von daher sind möchte ich das nochmal in
den vordergrund stellen also wie also
nicht die usa in den letzten tagen so
kritisiert worden politik laute was tut
mir leid das korrigieren sie mich aber
ich habe gelesen von ihnen eben auch den
kommentar dass sie anderer meinung sind
als die stiko das müssen wir das ist
akzeptiert aber sie haben ja auch gesagt
in einem interview die stiko hat eine
außenseiterposition wenn sie bei dieser
position bleibt die impfungen nicht
allgemein zu empfehlen haben sie ja
sozusagen auch kritik geübt in dieser
form also das ist ja sag ich kritik aber
es gab politischer druck
also meine persönliche position ist die
das und ich komme gleich zu begründung
dass die stiko haltung nicht wichtig ist
und aus seiner position bezieht sich für
mich im wesentlichen also auch die
länder an denen wir uns orientieren
insbesondere auch die vereinigten
staaten dazu benutzt das land wo ich
zehn jahre gelebt habe gute kontakte wo
ich auch noch eine gastprofessur habe
wollen diese belange sehr intensiv
diskutiert habe herzig hat aber eben
schon angedeutet dass er die situation
goldkinder für nicht vergleichbar hält
mit der situation amerikanische darauf
komme ich gleich noch einmal zurück das
ja ein sehr wichtiger punkt rezepte
machen und ich bin zwar anderen ahnung
aber es trotzdem das bedeutsam das ein
ganz ganz ganz bedeutung
also wir haben hier das muss man sich
vor augen führen aus mal dass ich nicht
die möglichkeit dass wir die kinder
impfen oder wir lassen ist und die
kinder also erkranken nicht und sind
nicht geimpft also kommen sie so durch
sondern aus meiner sicht ist es so dass
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die kinder
bei wieder normal im unterricht also
ohne maske also volle schulen und zwar
sonst mit der welt ab
während sich sehr viele kinder
infizieren somit muss man vergleichen
das risiko den
lektionen mit dem risiko der impfung und
auch das infektionsrisiko hat wenn man
die fraktion hat hat ein risiko
beispielsweise eine myokarditis zu
bekommen also diese eben schon von der
angesprochene entzündung des herzmuskels
gewebes meistens ist der beutel umsatz
herzform noch mit entzündet und das habe
ich auch also war der das habe ich auch
bei der erkrankung bei der erkrankung
sind aber zahlreiche andere organe
gefährdet im wesentlichen vereinfacht
gesprochen alle organe in denen ich an
der relativ hohe dichte von sogenannten
ac2 sektoren habe und das sind viele das
ist die nieren lassen
es ist herbst also das ist das leber
betroffen sogar die gefäße somit kinder
die sich infizieren können auch
langfristig schäden entwickeln von der
infektionen die wir jetzt noch gar nicht
richtig abschätzen können was wir auch
wissen ist dass und zumindest in england
also in england ist es so dass ungefähr
eines von 100 kindern die erkrankten ins
krankenhaus muss dass seine konservative
abgezogen und es wird geschätzt dass
irgendwo zwischen 2 bis 4 prozent der
kinder die erkranken
also nicht erkennt dass ich nur
infizieren sondern der kinder die auch
symptome bekommen das muss man
unterscheiden also zwei bis vier prozent
haben nur über monate weg symptome
daher also komme ich also in der
abwägung auch was die langfristigen
risiken angeht komme ich zu dem ergebnis
dass die impfung besser ist als die
erkrankung die alternative wenn jetzt
sagen wenn es so wäre der stadt alle zu
impfen oder viele zu impfen würden nur
wenige erkannte das ist ja was in der
vergangenheit gab haben in der
vergangenheit sind ja relativ weniger
kinder erkannt daher haben wir auch
weniger komplikationen
diese alternative sehe ich nicht mehr
wahr wir müssen das jetzt kommende
schuljahr
das müssen wir anders bedienen als es
letztlich vorher daher haben wir nur die
alternative dass wir viele inseln oder
es werden viele erkranken und das ist
der grund weshalb ich die position
vertrete die ich wie sie eben richtig
auch zusammengefasst
also zwei unterschiedliche positionen
bei allem respekt wir gehen die
argumente durchkommen auch sofort noch
auf die fragen die die userinnen und
user schon gestellt haben wir schauen
uns ganz kurzen beitrag an der auch noch
mal einige aspekte zusammen fast unter
anderem auch die position der stiko und
die lage auch der familien uns der
eltern kinder jugendliche und die kogit
im spritze klar ist für 12 bis 17
jährige in deutschland empfiehlt die
stiko die ständige impfkommission diese
spritze nur in bestimmten fällen etwa
bei vorerkrankungen wie immunschwäche
oder fettleibigkeit eine allgemeine
corona impfempfehlung gibt es hier nicht
ein grund so die wissenschaftler
die fehlenden daten es gebe noch zu
wenig studien zu wenig wissen etwa über
nebenwirkungen und risiken anders sehen
das die zuständigen experten in den usa
oder bei der eu die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema hat eine
allgemeine impfempfehlung ausgesprochen
ab 12 jahren für die wirkstoffe von
biontech und moderner auch bei den
jüngeren seien diese impfstoffe wirksam
und sicher
das hätten die bisherigen studien klar
gezeigt dass ist die lage viele familien
stehen jetzt vor der frage kinder impfen
ja oder nein
in deutschland gibt es etwa 4,5
millionen 12 bis 17 jährige 900.000
haben sich bislang impfen lassen gegen
korona hervester zeit einfach noch mal
die frage wir haben ja jetzt gehört die
ema hat im mai ja bereits den impfstoff
so haben wir alle verfolgt für 12 bis 17
jährige zugelassen von beyond eckpfeiler
vor wenigen tagen eben jetzt auch grünes
licht für moderne hat da frage ich mich
doch als laie machen die denn bei der
ema in amsterdam nicht auch eine
nutzen-risiko-abwägung wenn sie diese
zulassung geben und ist das nicht die
gleiche basis die die ema hat nämlich
studien die ja die hersteller
doch auch liefern müssen also nach dem
motto da sind doch zahlen
es ist ja nicht so dass jetzt ein
produzent ein hersteller ankommt und
sagt ich habe hier eine kleine mixtur
die möchte ich zu lassen nein die müssen
ja auch mit studien ankommen und dann
eben studien an kindern ja also ich
würde sagen die wissenschaftler und die
mitarbeiter in den
bei der em also der europäischen
zulassungsbehörde wie auch bei der
amerikanischen f dr
die machen aus unserer sicht dann hervor
in den job und sie bemühen sich gerade
in der pandemie situation
sag ich mal möglichst gut die daten die
vorliegend zu bewerten aber vielleicht
ist eines ganz wichtig was falsch in dem
beitrag war was sie den sie eben
dargestellt haben die ema wie auch die
fdp geben keine empfehlungen sondern ist
einfach so dass die beiden behörden
prüfen also die prüfen ob die wünsche
des pharmaunternehmens die vorgetragen
werden so wollen wir unseren impfstoff
zugelassen haben ob die belastbar durch
die studien die dazu vorgelegt werden
belegt werden
und da ist es natürlich gerade dass der
effekt der aspekt der immunogenität also
macht der mensch der games wird
antikörper macht das schützende
antikörper ist der geschützt also die
frage placebo oder impfstoff empfänger
ist das ist es aber das ist gut
darstellt waren die frage von
nebenwirkungen ist immer eine die im
prinzip eine längere nach beobachtung
nach sich ziehen
bei erwachsenen würden wir sagen ist es
oft so dass im vierteljahr das gut
dargestellt ist bei kindern und
jugendlichen sind wir in einer völlig
anderen situation das ist ein thema das
wir kinderärzte immer wieder vortragen
denn kinder und jugendliche sind in
einem biologischen entwicklungsprozess
ich habe an anderer stelle mal gesagt
der neu geboren ist wenn wir jetzt über
impfungen von zeugen sprechen
verdreifacht in zwölf monaten seien
körpervolumen sein körpergewicht was für
eine ungeheure entwicklungsdynamik an in
uns menschen und bei den jugendlichen
die wir jetzt bedachten 12 bis 17 jahre
ist es die pubertät da kommt es zu
enormen umstellung von einer natur
veränderungen der expression von ac2
rezeptoren zum beispiel auch es kommt zu
einflüssen auf das immunsystem und die
interaktion in dieser situation zu
impfen
wie können wir einfach nicht und die
können wir am ende des tages auch nur
durch langzeitbeobachtung erfahren nun
sind wir in der pandemie wir müssen
einen wir müssen einen saal best beste
empfehlungen entwickelt denn wir können
nicht zehn jahre warten ist zu empfehlen
das weiß ich jetzt fragen ich meine so
genau richtig das ist seit jahren mehr
weiß genau was geht gar nicht wir haben
eine spezielle situation das wissen wir
wir können jetzt das nicht nicht sein
zustand erzeugen wie wir den in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten bei anderen
impfstoffen gehabt haben aber ich will
noch mal sagen wenn jetzt die immer mit
einer neuen nebenwirkung überrascht wird
erinnere nur an
vector impfstoff und die thrombosen dann
sagt sie können wir jetzt auch nicht
bewerten aber der impfstoff funktioniert
ja und dann schreibt sie einen
warnhinweis hinein und damit geht die
verantwortung an die impfenden ärzte und
die individuen die sich impfen lassen
oder die eltern die für kinder
entscheiden
genau das gleiche das hat sie bei dem
vector impfstoffen gemacht und das hat
sie jetzt auch bei beiden impfstoffen
beiden m rna impfstoffen gemacht sagt
also da ist ein risiko wir im augenblick
empfinden das aber nicht also hochwertig
dass wir den impfstoff jetzt verbieten
müssten
das ist auch wichtig wir brauchen diese
impfstoffe und die pandemie zu
überwinden und deshalb lassen wir euch
jetzt auf ihr müsst etwas beobachten
nach einem jahr in amerika sind sogar
nur notfall zulassung bei uns ins
bedingte zulassung prüfen wäre ob das
ausreichend gewesen ist und so geht es
weiter die impfstoffhersteller müssen ja
mehrere jahre nach untersuchen an der
schwelle befinden wir uns und das ist
natürlich dann in der entweder in
betrachtung eines landes mag das
unterschiedlich sein den usa sind in der
altersgruppe etwa 135 jugendliche
gestorben in dem verlauf der pandemie
in deutschland sind zwei jugendliche in
dieser altersgruppe mit vorerkrankungen
bedauerlicherweise auch zu tode gekommen
das heißt wir sehen die schweregrad der
erkrankung ist was anderes den usa sind
50 prozent der schweren fälle im prozent
menschen mit maximaler adipositas
übergewicht das ist etwas was wir in
deutschland auch nicht so sehen das
heißt wir müssen hier betrachten und das
ist ja erst mal eine gute nachricht für
alle beteiligten dass die
krankheitssymptome niedrig sind hörigen
stehen wir da nicht allein in england
die englische stiko ist genau zu der
gleichen risikoeinschätzung gekommen wie
hier und dort ist ja super ist zum teil
jetzt ja 90 prozent der fälle sind die
delta variante und die delta variante
hat in england zwar zu einer schnelleren
ausbreitung über prag übertragen geführt
nicht aber zu einer höheren
krankheitskosten den jugendlichen also
die die jugendlichen oder kinder nehmen
rezeptions geschehen teil aber es sind
nicht mehr im krankenhaus aufgenommen
worden
aber dann müssen wir professor
lauterbach da müssen wir sie erlaubt
aber eben fragen wenn die stiko wenn
herr z die stiko sozusagen die hüter der
porzellankiste sind also vorsicht
vorsicht vorsicht bevor wir empfehlen
wenn wir jetzt verstanden haben den
unterschied zu lassen
und empfehlen heißt da muss ich 100
prozentig sicher sein dass die risiken
nicht so groß sind ist es für uns denn
nicht vielleicht sogar sehr sehr sehr
gut dass die stiko so vorsichtig ist was
ist der grund dass die politik und sie
auch sagen nein
die stiko ist zurückhaltend wir müssen
die zwölf- bis 17-jährigen impfen lass
ich es richtig finde dass die stiko also
vorsichtig ist und was er geschrieben
hat also dass die also zulassungsbehörde
ema also kann empfehlungen ausspricht
dass selbst das richtige kostüm bin ich
anderer meinung also nicht mehr über das
ist auch richtig dass in england aus
seine position vertreten wird bevor ich
das vergessen
in england wurde eine ähnliche position
vertreten wenig deko sie verträgt das
ist ganz klar wichtig aber es gibt
zahlreiche andere länder wo es anders
ist also frankreich kanada vereinigten
staaten israel also daten ausgewertet
worden sind und wo man auf der grundlage
dessen also was man sehen konnte
ungefähr das gesehen hat was man auch
erwartet hatte das heißt man sieht diese
seltenen komplikationen bei kindern
man sieht diese mio kredit ist die
parität ist man sieht einfach andere
sehr seltene komplikationen aber es ist
nichts neues dazugekommen und also es
ist richtig dass wir im letzten jahr in
deutschland hat weniger kinder gehabt
haben die sich infiziert haben auch nur
zwei sterbefälle jeweils mit großem
erfolg mit wesentlichen vorerkrankungen
somit also ist das richtig aber wir sind
eben hier ist in einer ganz neuen
situation wir sind in der situation über
sorgen und england aber das ist jetzt so
beta variante hat nicht so viele kinder
betroffen
das war bisher nicht so aber die ist was
so koch ja noch die schule fängt jetzt
an die klassen werden an zusagen die
klassen sind sozusagen dann gefüllt mit
kinder wenn ich den unterricht anrollen
lassen will
dann werde ich hohe fallzahlen haben das
ist ganz klar die data warnt ist auch so
rechnerisch ungefähr so ansteckend wie
die windpocken sonst alles was wenn der
vergangenheit gehabt haben spielt
überhaupt keine rolle kann so groß da
wollen wir werden dann im wesentlich das
ganze schuljahr geht ja ein ganzes jahr
und werden über dieses schuljahr hinweg
haben wir die situation dass während
wieder viele kinder impfen oder es
werden sehr viele kinder erkranken
das ist die alternative jetzt spricht
die herr professor wissen sie schmunzeln
sagen gerade nein den punkt
ja ich bin an der gegenposition
interessiert ich weiß nicht wo ich den
vergleich mit den windpark gehört also
windpocken sind die ansteckende
erkrankung die wir haben die revolution
zahl von windpocken ist ungefähr 20 bis
25 also ein vielfaches höher
aber zugegebenermaßen die delta variante
hat eine ansteckungsrate die doppelt so
hoch ist wie das was wir vorher gesehen
haben also wenn das vorher etwa bei 3
viel eis gelegen hat liegt es also jetzt
bei ungefähr acht das heißt ein ein
erkrankter oder infizierter steckt
statistisch gesehen acht andere an
bei windpocken das sind besonderheit
dieses virus weil es sehr lange
außerhalb des organismus überleben kann
kann es faktisch über über mehrere
minuten quasi im raum schweben bis es
den nächsten menschen der sich aber
grundsätzlich sind uns glaube ich einige
beobachter ist ja aber live berichten
ist ja auch in barcelona mallorca
überall kindern endlich nimmt zu dass
man muss vielleicht war es auch zu spät
sind gemeint in dem sich für die zügige
doch nicht etwas es nicht etwas unter
der ansteckung art und maß an aber es
kommt fast daran wenn man so will ja und
es ist eben also das ist nicht mehr
vergleichbar
das war mal ein punkt also mit dem
ursprünglichen euro pro nacht das ist
nicht mehr mit dem wir jetzt übt
vergleichbar sondern wir haben hier eine
ansteckung die also mindestens um den
faktor 2 hört ist und wir haben die
situation dass wir versuchen werden
im gegensatz zum letzten jahr wieder an
relativ regulieren also unterricht
anzubieten und das ist das was zu vielen
fällen führen ja also ist es ganz
wichtig also es ist ganz ganz wichtig
für die kinder und jugendlichen auch
dass sie wieder einen normalen regulären
unterricht zurückkommen das ist das hat
schwerwiegende andere probleme
hinterlassen
die alle noch sage ich mal bearbeitet
und verarbeitet werden müssen und ein
set vordringlichen ziele muss wieder
normale lebensführung für kinder und
jugendliche sein und insofern will ich
sagen das ist genau das was die stiko
macht wir versuchen im augenblick mit
unterstützung der biss
mannschaft am robert-koch-institut zum
beispiel zu erfassen
wie hoch die belastung in dieser
altersgruppe sein kann mit neuen
varianten wenn jetzt zum beispiel
theoretisch oder auch praktisch eine
vierte welle kommt das geht nicht
vergessen
aber ich sage mal es ist auch so dass
wir sorgfältig prüfen müssen und wenn
die daten aus amerika was die sicherheit
angeht die die stehen noch aus weil ich
sag mal die große welle von den sechs
bis sieben millionen geimpften die
kombiniert oder haben jetzt ihre zweite
impfung bekommen und wir werden das
hoffe ich
in den nächsten zwei oder vier wochen
von den amerikanern erfahren das liegt
zunächst mal im land ihre daten
auswerten bevor sie nach ausgegeben ist
auch normal
sie wollen sie sicherlich nicht von
deutschland kommentiert bekommen bevor
sie selber drüber nachgedacht haben aber
ich sag mal trotzdem wissen wir dass
also und nochmal ganz wichtigen dazu
sagen die stiko schläft nicht sondern
wir versuchen das infektionsgeschehen zu
erfassen und wenn zb es so ist wie
professor lauterbach andeutet dass es
möglicherweise eben ein erhöhtes
aufkommen von infektionen gibt und dass
die meisten kinder haben infektionen
aber keine krankheit was aber dann
natürlich auch zu einer steigerung der
krankheit führen könnte dann ändert sich
unter umständen die risikobetrachtung
die war und das heißt dann werden wir
auch zeitnah entsprechend die stiko
empfehlung anpassen sind viele fragen
die es jetzt hier schon gibt sie
schließen aber hervorragend an diese
fragen ich würde sie gerne stellen nach
einem kleinen beitrag von meiner
kollegin christiane hübscher die
sozusagen das alles mal in einen topf
geworfen hat nämlich die ganze
diskussion das risiko für kinder schwer
zu erkranken ist nicht so groß aber sie
gehen jetzt wieder in die schule was er
lauterbach sagt dann ist das risiko sich
zu infizieren wieder höher und
mittendrin zwischen politikern experten
stiko und schulleitung sind halt eltern
und kinder schauen wir uns den beitrag
an dann kommen gleich die kritischen
fragen
es ist eine der meistdiskutierten fragen
im moment soll ich mein kind impfen
lassen ja sagt die politik in einer
video konferenz der gesundheitsminister
der länder mit jens spahn ist soeben
eine extra impfkampagne für zwölf- bis
17-jährige beschlossen worden
was das thema der kinder und jugend
impfungen angeht haben wir einen
einstimmigen beschluss gefasst dass wir
dieses angebot jetzt in allen ländern
unterbreiten wollen wir wollen dann
zusätzlich im september dann auch in die
schulen gehen und dort noch einmal diese
impf angebote machen um da wirklich
alles auch auszuloten wer das will kann
das dann noch annehmen damit über geht
die politik die ständige impfkommission
kurz stiko die empfiehlt die kurve
kämpfen bisher nur für vor erkrankte
kinder stieg josef merkens reagiert
gereizt ich halte den druck den die
politik ausübt eigentlich für wenig ist
die debatte über kinder impfungen seien
nur eine stellvertreter diskussion zu
den weiteren verlauf der pandemie in
deutschland wäre es absolut erforderlich
dass sich die 18 bis 59 jährigen
vollständig mit dem reichlich
verfügbaren impfstoff impfen lassen
die kinder spielen für die epidemiologie
in deutschland und für den verlauf der
brannte wie eine ausgesprochen
untergeordnete rolle
doch die impfbereitschaft der
erwachsenen stagniert dazu kommt der
schulstart in mehreren bundesländern
deshalb setzt die politik nun offensiv
auf die jüngeren
niemand übt druck auf die impfungen von
kindern und jugendlichen ist allein
entscheidungen der eltern gemeinsam mit
ihren kindern und das wird auch so
bleiben
die politik schafft fakten die stiko
zögert verunsichert zurück bleiben viele
eltern und kinder ja erstmal die frage
an sie herr lauterbach diese
entscheidung die tatsache dass die
politik sich über die position der stiko
hinwegsetzt ist das nicht klar dass das
zu einer verunsicherung bei den eltern
führt wenn soll ich jetzt auf einmal den
politikern folgen und nicht mehr den
experten so wie es bisher war
also folgen muss hier niemand
irgendjemandem sondern ist dann im
angebot was gemacht wird oder sie sagen
klar ist es ja auch klar dass die eltern
sich natürlich fragen jetzt sozusagen
haben politik und stieg und
unterschiedliche position und der ball
wird den eltern ihr zugespielt das ist
ja richtig wir uns im beitrag gehört
herr scholz alle haben es ja noch mal
frau schwesig betonte es ist keine
pflicht selbstverständlich aber es
erhöht ja auch ein bisschen den druck
die
die eltern haben jetzt den ball und
müssen jetzt entscheiden was ist denn
jetzt richtig ja die eltern haben
sowieso den ball und die kinder auch als
sie das entscheiden sich die eltern
allein sondern die kinder es kann ja
nicht gegen den willen der kinder
gegeben wird
aber so ist das halt gekommen also die
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht die lage
wäre eine andere
trotzdem also muss man das aushalten die
stiko sein das renommierte also sauber
vorgehende auch international anerkannte
einrichtung ist eben hier einer anderen
meinung und also das impfangebot was
jetzt vorgehalten wird
was die länder und der bund zur
verfügung stellen ist ein angebot also
an die eltern
es war ja eine zeit lang so dass
tatsächlich die impfung für kinder auch
deshalb nicht also angeboten werden
sollte und auch von der stieg und nicht
also befürwortet wurde
weil argumentiert wurde man würde den
impfstoff nötiger bei den älteren
menschen benötigen
das ist nicht mehr der fall wir haben
jetzt genug impfstoff und ich bin auch
nicht also der meinung von herrn mertens
richter so offen sagen darf das ist also
der politik oder den politischen gremien
ihr darum gegangen ist war den kindern
zu kompensieren was uns bei den
erwachsenen dank impfmüdigkeit nicht
gelegt darum geht dass zumindest mir
nicht ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
die kinder selbst in einer situation wo
die wahrscheinlichkeit hoch ist dass sie
also sich infizieren mit der delta
variante oder mit einer später und
variante dass die kinder dann also mit
der impfung besser bedient sind da ich
könnte das ich finde da auch sehr jetzt
ins detail gehen was dich also jemand
medizinischen gründe angeht aber es ist
so wenn es jetzt so wäre das ist die
kinder mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht erwischen würde auch simon mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit sich nicht
anstecken
dann könnte man zur impfung anders steht
ich stehe zur impfung gehe ich gehe weil
ich davon ausgehe dass die ungeimpften
kinder im laufe der nächsten monate sehr
hohes risiko tragen werden sich zu
infizieren
das ist leider so und das ist die
grundlage meiner scheidung der präsident
ist es aber
nicht nur sozusagen ihr der vorsitzende
der steeger mertin sondern auch der
präsident der ärztekammer nordrhein
rudolf henke äußerte sich heute ziemlich
skeptisch so ein bisschen was jetzt
beschlossen worden ist er sagt meine
präferenz wäre alle erwachsenen die
kontakte zu kindern haben lassen sich
erst mal impfen und dann reden wir neu
über eine stiko empfehlung also auch da
ist bei ihm so ein bisschen das gefühl
weil es bei den erwachsenen nicht
vorangeht müssen jetzt sozusagen die
kinder an die herangetreten werden naja
wer sie sich das realistisch anschauen
wenn wenn ein oder zwei kinder infiziert
sind in der klasse und ich mache
regulären unterricht also wieder 30
kinder in der klasse und die kinder
tragen möglicherweise keine masken mehr
was soll denn da passieren
dann werden sicher zahlreiche kinder
anstecken so was sagt ob der lehrer ist
geimpft ist oder nicht das spiel
überhaupt keine rolle
also ist man immer gut für den lehrer
aber dass also das impfen der
erwachsenen weiter vorantreiben da sind
sie natürlich auch der meinung wir haben
viele fragen bekommen was sagen sie denn
dazu dass jetzt sozusagen die stiko
übergangen wird
da gibt es jetzt mehrere kommentare wir
hören immer wir müssen auf die stiko
hören auf die stiko hören und jetzt wird
sozusagen die position der stiko
ignoriert wie so setzt sich die politik
über die meinung der stiko eigentlich
hinweg weil es doch noch gar keine
luftfilter digitale konzepte gibt also
andere sachen kritische frage von
kerstin thomsen rocker über facebook ok
also zunächst würde ich versuchen das
noch mal so ein bisschen ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen
wir wir wir sind ja im gespräch und ich
habe auch nicht den eindruck herr
lauterbach sagt ist auch selber dass die
stiko als institution nicht geschätzt
wird
bin noch nicht sicher ob er uns sagen
sollte man setzt sich über die stiko
hinweg die stiko argumentiert ja nicht
gegen die impfung sondern sie sagt nur
die datenlage die wir im augenblick
haben
unter berücksichtigung der krankheit bei
kindern ist im augenblick so dass das
gleichgewicht nicht unbedingt zu gunsten
der impfstoffe ausfällt heißt aber nicht
dass man dem stoff ist er zugelassen das
ist eine entscheidung der zulassung
würde immer gewesen dass man die nicht
geben kann
also insofern
niemals würde die stiko gegen die
impfung argumentieren sie sagt nur wir
sehen denn den benefit für die hälften
menschen nicht so eindeutig wie die
politik das vielleicht sieht wir müssen
uns auch darüber klar sein in schulen
dass wir ja im augenblick keine
impfstoffe haben für kinder unter zwölf
jahren das heißt zwei drittel der
population die wir betrachten wollen von
der kita bis zur sechsten schulklasse
die können wir gar nicht impfen das
heißt wir werden nur einen teilaspekt in
der schule erzeugen
wir wissen aus der cosmo studie also so
eine erhebung die die universität erfurt
durchführt das wahrscheinlich vielleicht
60 prozent der jugendlichen sich impfen
lassen wollen
das heißt wir leisten einen beitrag aber
wir lösen das problem nicht und noch mal
kinder die sich infizieren haben nicht
gleichzeitig mit 19 19 wer die krankheit
sondern die meisten der kinder 98 95
prozent haben im prinzip nicht
symptomatisch infektionen könnten aber
die infektion natürlich weiter tragen
und wer ist da gefährdet das sind die
erwachsenen das ist glaube ich was
professor merkens ausdrücken wollte wenn
wir die krankheitslast die schweren
verläufe die die intensiv behandlungen
die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems wenn wir die
verhindern wollen dann sollte losgelöst
von der betrachtung der kinder und
jugendlichen ein fokus darauf liegen
wir haben jetzt 60 prozent der menschen
geimpft in deutschland erstmal weltweit
gesehen ist das ein super ergebnis
wir müssen uns darüber klar sein dass
ungefähr 10 12 prozent der menschen
genesene sind sind wir also schon bei 72
prozent
und wenn jetzt 85 prozent so eine hürde
wäre die wir nehmen müssen
dann sind es eigentlich nicht 85 prozent
dämpfen sondern 85% geschützte erzählen
ja auch die genesenen dazu und insofern
das sind wir eigentlich schon nahe dran
und dass das gesamtproblem ist dort
sicher anzugehen und ich sage es nochmal
ja wir werden wir werden nicht müde wir
haben nicht irgendwo vor fünf wochen der
entscheidung getroffen oder eine
empfehlung getroffen wir empfehlen am
ende des tages nur sondern wir wollen
das weiter entwickeln und wenn sich zum
beispiel jetzt eben angesichts der der
entwicklung die man erwartet im august
september oktober quelle vielleicht wenn
sich das dort neu darstellt auch im
fokus auf kinder und jugendliche
dann werden wir das natürlich sorgfältig
betrachten und auch sorgfältig und
zeitnah und zeit war heißt für uns im
prinzip wir müssen ja mit unseren
empfehlungen noch durch die beurteilung
der landesbehörden gehen durch die
beurteilung der fachgesellschaften das
heißt wir können
von heute auf morgen eine meinung
rausgeben nicht weil wir es nicht
wollten das können wir schon sondern
weil einfach bis zur veröffentlichung
einer empfehlung an eine systematik
vorgeschrieben ist die
gesundheitsbehörden der länder haben das
recht dazu zu kommentieren wir müssen
die kommentare aufgreifen und müssen sie
einarbeiten und meint das dauert am ende
des tages eben 24 mal natürlich wenn man
einfach nur mal sich anschaut die fragen
der userinnen und user die wir bekommen
es geht halt um den eindruck und der
eindruck ist halt schon ist man ihn nur
vier schreiben über youtube meine frage
wäre nun warum hat man eine
impfkommission wenn man sich am ende
über sie hinweg setzt und ihre meinung
nicht oder nur wenig beachtet und der
gleiche user schreibt auch frage an
professor z
sie und die stiko haben ja immer gesagt
dass die datenlage bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen zu dünnen seil professor
lauterbach sagt es gebe weltweit genug
daten in dieser gruppe was stimmt denn
nun also da ist ja so ein bisschen auch
die verunsicherung nun auf einmal da
dass man eine kommission hat und in dem
fall sozusagen die meinung nicht richtig
gefragt ist ich will mal so sagen die
daten die wir haben von jugendlichen aus
den usa die ältesten publizierten daten
sind von 23 juni und die betreffend vor
allen dingen die erkenntnisse die man
bei jungen erwachsenen gehabt hat und
erste geimpft und ich sage mal diese
große gruppe von sechs oder sieben
millionen geimpften jugendlichen das
interessiert uns schon sehr
die hat man ja begonnen mitte mai zu
impfen mai juni juli das heißt die die
herzmuskelentzündung kommt ja erst im
regelfall erst nach der zweiten impfung
dass davon können wir jetzt eigentlich
erst mit dem versatz von etwa zwei
wochen in diesen tagen daten erwarten
gehabt und ich sag mal ansonsten ist
nichts was nicht schon am 23 juni
bekannt gewesen wäre müsste ich jetzt
noch mal fragen zum abschluss er lauter
war ist es nicht so dass auch millionen
geht oder 100.000 kinder eine große zahl
von kindern auch in israel und anderen
ländern geimpft worden sind so dass ich
mir jetzt sage da hatten doch auch
genügend daten ja es kommt da waren wie
man es sieht so was einen genügend
aussagen nicht geübt und also es ist
richtig dass wir also bei den kindern
noch amerikanische daten auswerten aber
von den daten die wir bekommen haben das
waren die ersten zwei millionen wenn man
so will sie ausgewertet sind da haben
wir also sagen
also die wir abladen können wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit an bürokratie das
konnte man dann auch ungefähr
vergleichen mit dem risiko bei
erwachsenen die daten gibt es auch aus
israel
es ist aber also ganz klar dass das
einfach eine risikoabwägung ist weil
noch einmal ich gehe davon aus wenn
jetzt die schule wieder beginnen also es
geht wirklich los als wir dann hohe
zahlen von infizierten haben und diese
infizierten kinder tragen ein höheres
risiko
auch im übrigen an andere kredites zu
erkranken
neben vielen anderen erkrankungen die
mögliche als ist hier der fall ist bei
der impfung
natürlich war der impfung sprechen wir
in der größenordnung von ein fall auf
mehrere 10.000 das ist ungefähr die
größenordnung und dann meistens selbst
heilen der prozess wobei man also hätte
also mann wobei man beachten muss das
nach hinten raus natürlich daraus auf
rhythmus störungen entstehen können die
jahrzehnte später kommen lassen aber
eben wie ganz seltene fälle und ich habe
aber eine viel höhere die also viel
höheres risiko dass ich das gleiche
betrag bekommen
bei kindern die sich infiziert haben das
was auch logisch ist was ich habe hier
das hier wirklich also schädliche immun
geschehen
das habe ich bei der impfung hat
begrenzt und ich habe es also im prinzip
war der erkrankung vergrößern
somit hängt alles davon ab wie groß wird
dann die infektionswelle sein die ich
mit der impfung behindern könnte wenn
die infektionswelle groß ist dann
überwiegt ganz klar aus meiner sicht die
gefahr durch die erkrankung
genau das versuchen wir versuchen wir ja
auch abzuschätzen das versuchen wir auch
abzuschätzen mit den epidemiologen des
robert koch instituts dazu werden
mangels heute modellierungen
durchgeführt und ich sag mal die die
bekommen wir auch regelhaft vorgestellt
auch sagt man im verlauf dieser woche
wieder und das kann zu einer
neubewertung führen über alles würde ich
mal sagen ich glaube ich schon wir
lernen ja immer aus und wir sind ja in
der krise in der wir uns entwickeln
es geht sehr schnell ich glaube schon
auch die kommunikation hätte besser sein
können vielleicht von der jako
vielleicht auch von der politik
ich frag mich auch also ich sag mal so
ist für mich jetzt persönlich als mensch
und kinderarzt schade dass wir irgendwie
immer über medien kommuniziert als stadt
irgendwann mal einfach den schalter zu
machen und sagen lasst uns mal darüber
reden was ihr denkt ich glaube da können
beide seiten was von lernen weil
natürlich ist es ganz wichtig bei sowas
wie impfungen und auch in der krise aus
der wir jetzt so ein bisschen das gefühl
haben wir kommen langsam raus dass die
menschen vertrauen haben vertrauen in
die stiko vertrauen in die
gesundheitspolitik und die wege die auf
dem weg die die empfehlungen oder die
maßnahmen die wir unternehmen
ich sag mal das können wir glaube ich
besser machen und wenn mein wunsch ist
auch ein politiker jetzt hier im raum
mit uns dann wäre das einfach toll wenn
man das mit nimmt und sagt lasst uns so
vorher drüber reden bevor es die
schlagzeile in der bild zeitung wird
oder so wir merken wir haben das ja sehr
nett jetzt mit ihnen beiden diskutiert
merken wo die unterschiede sind aber
auch wo die gemeinsamkeiten sind wo die
gemeinsamkeit bei uns allen userinnen
und user eingeschlossen ist dass wir
nicht die kristallkugel haben um in die
zukunft zu blicken
herr lauterbach sie haben es gesagt wenn
wir wüssten wie es denn kommt mit der
welle und die delta sich verhält dann
wären wir schlauer
insofern müssen wir das abwarten wir
danken aber ganz ganz ganz herzlich
herr lauterbach dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben und das ganze
eingeschätzt haben vielen dank für ihre
sicht der dinge und wir werden das ganze
gespannt weiterverfolgen grüße nach köln
und schönen namen doch vielen dank dank
ihnen auch wieder schauen vielen dank
und jan sie einfach mal noch die
schnelle faktische frage die jetzt hier
kam von einer claudia overath
wahrscheinlich mutter bitte diese kurze
frage dürfen denn kinder ab 14 jahren
ohne zustimmung der eltern geimpft
werden wenn ja kann ich den schriftlich
widersprechen und dann gegebenenfalls
klagen
sie wäre ängste jetzt auf einmal
entstehen wenn es heißt wir gehen auch
mit im teams demnächst in die schulen
das war er in schleswig-holstein schon
so angekündigt um das limit zu pushen da
kommen schon einige sorgen ja ja ja das
ist eine nicht ganz einfache situation
weil
aber sagen wir natürlich schon oder auch
im gesamten wissen auch eigentlich der
medizinischen versorgung von kindern und
jugendlichen in dem moment wo kinder
oder jugendliche inhalt sich damit
befassen können nehmen wir sie
eigentlich in der entscheidung wird das
tun wir in der kinder- und jugendmedizin
im prinzip schon ab frühen alter sagt
mal grundschulalter bei den impfungen
natürlich ein bisschen weiter gehend und
im prinzip geht man davon aus dass zb
ein 16 jähriger jugendlicher in der lage
ist für sich alleine zu entscheiden ob
er eine impfung haben will oder nicht
und das ist sage ich mal auch etwas was
ihm glaube ich im praktischen alltag in
den ambulanzen in den praxen der der
impfenden ärzte und ärztinnen aus dem
stattfindet wir sind jetzt hier
vielleicht in der kritischen situation
juristisch gesehen sind natürlich im
prinzip die jugendlichen bis zum
erreichen des achtzehnten geburtstag von
der einwilligung ihrer eltern abhängig
und angesichts der sagen ich mal etwas
doch sehr angeheizten diskussion im
lande würde es vielleicht glück für die
kollegen und kolleginnen die impfen im
prinzip aber bis zum alter von 18 jahren
schon eine eine bestätigung der eltern
zu haben weil es könnte tatsächlich so
sein dass ein elternteil dann zb den
impfenden arts verklagt weil im prinzip
das kind juristisch gesehen so vermute
ich bin jetzt kein jurist grundsätzlich
aber so sehe ich persönlich die sachlage
eigentlich für diese fragestellungen
noch nicht alleine geschäftsfähig wäre
und dann würde man risiko eingehen also
bei 14 jährigen ist es noch ein bisschen
anders so ab 16 sagen wir dürfen die
eigentlich selbst entscheiden und das
ist auch humus es häufig so jetzt in
einer bestimmten situation wo sehr
angeregt diskutiert wird würde ich sagen
als arzt würde ich mir immer noch die
einwilligung der eltern oder eines
elternteils geben damit er hat sicher
auch ihre empfehlung gab zu sagen an
alle vielleicht so viel
fingerspitzengefühl zu haben dass man
sich doch an einen tisch setzt und ja
sie sind ja nun mediziner dann kann sie
dorotheas bakirci schreibt über facebook
ist der impfstoff für kinder in der
zusammensetzung und auch in der menge
eigentlich der gleiche wie für
erwachsene
erwachsene sind vielleicht schon einfach
geben doppelt geimpft und so weiter
wissen also wie die nadel aussieht so
umher aber die interessante frage wie
sieht das bei kindern aus ist genau
weniger also ich sage bei der
altersgruppe 12 bis 17 jahre also oder
12 bis 16 jahre bei dem impfstoff der
hier auch in mainz entwickelt wurde ist
es ja ein anderes alters fans etwas
gewesen ist es so dass in dieser alte in
diesem alter das fenster der gleiche
impfstoff verwendet wurde wie bei den
erwachsenen bei den jetzt laufenden
studien sowohl von moderner als auch
weil byron tag ist es so dass man also
von fünf bis elf jahre
dass man tatsächlich noch einmal eine
kleine dosis findung macht das heißt man
hat den impfstoff in der jetzt schon
bekannten konzentration und hat dann
noch zwei dosierungen niedriger also ich
glaube wenn es rechts gelesen habe der
der zugelassene impfstoff hat 30
mikrogramm und jetzt wird auch noch zehn
und 20 mikrogramm untersucht warum wir
können es nicht voraussagen ich gebe
ihnen ein beispiel bei dem schlusston
impfstoff den die säuglinge im ersten
lebenshalbjahr bekommen da ist die dosis
höher als bei dem impfstoff den
erwachsenen bekommen oder junge
schulkinder beim influenza beim
grippeimpfstoff ist es genau umgekehrt
mit anderen worten es gibt keine regel
mit dem wir das einen dreisatz
runterbrechen sondern wir müssen es
tatsächlich in unterschiedlichen
altersgruppen nochmal durch studien
belegen das geschieht das machen die
impfstoffhersteller auch sehr sorgfältig
und aus diesem grund glaube ich müssen
wir auch an ein gewisses längeres
zeitfenster akzeptieren dass ersten
studien bei fünf bis elfjährigen kommt
und der nächste schritt wäre dann
wahrscheinlich zwei bis vierjährige sein
und am schluss kommen die säuglinge dran
also ich würde mal sagen liebe dorothee
das war eine ausführliche spezial
antwort wie das ganze aussehen wir
danken ganz ganz ganz herzlich herr
professor z das war sehr interessant und
man lernt ja auch einfach in der
diskussion man kann unterschiedliche
standpunkte haben aber es gibt doch
gewisse gemeinsame nenner und wir haben
es gesagt man muss eben sehen wie sich
die dinge
entwickeln dann mögen positionen eben
auch verändert werden angepasst werden
aber das ist ja das prinzip learning und
das ganze beobachtet wir danken ganz
herzlich und hoffen dass wir ihre fragen
beantwortet haben
vielen dank für ihr interesse bis und
schönen abend